what's going on guys I'm continuing my
reviews for the trailers that came out
during this Super Bowl I've already done
transformers 4 and Captain America
Winter Soldier those are both of my
channel if you want to check those out
right now amazing spider-man 2 is a
movie that I am looking forward to
seeing because I really hope that it's
better than the first one
I didn't hate the first one I just
thought there was a lot of room for
improvement the first trailer that was
released a couple months ago didn't
really impress me that much I wasn't
really that into it I thought some of
the special effects looked pretty
cartoony the story just didn't feel very
important to me and it just didn't feel
like it was going in the right direction
and it felt like it just spoiled all
these really awesome Easter eggs that we
weren't really supposed to see yet but I
guess they want us to because there's
more of it in this one there's a full
three minute and 50 second trailer
online right now for this movie and
that's what I'm going to be reviewing
however I can legitimately say that this
one looks much better than the last one
this one did give me a lot more hope for
this movie in the last one did and that
is namely because of Jamie Foxx now in
this trailer at first he kind of
reminded me of his character in
collateral that kind of nerdy nervous
character that actually got him a Best
Supporting Actor nomination he looks
great in this movie this movie
definitely looks a lot better than the
last trailer the special effects do
actually look improved the villains seem
to make more sense in this trailer as
well electro actually seemed like okay
there is the main villain in green
Goblin's sort of there who knows how
much involvement he'll actually have
with the movie all gee Maddie's face
wasn't even in this trailer you just saw
the Rhino armored suit walking couple
times I don't know how much inclusion
he'll be in the movie either I have a
feeling that this is obviously going to
lead into the sinister six thing because
you see doc Ock's arms you see the
vultures wings that's something that is
extremely enticing to me that is pretty
awesome and outline where Jimmie Foxx is
like let's catch a spider
it looks like he's talking to somebody
I'm thinking that's Green Goblin I don't
know we'll have to see but it looks like
the sinister six is really stirring up
in this movie that's enticing to me I'm
excited to see that this movie does look
better than I thought it was going to be
I am excited to see what this movie
brings I'm really hoping it's better
than the first one I think it's going to
be Andrew Garfield looks great as Spidey
I like this joke at the end about the
chimney looks pretty cool what do you
guys think of this new trailer for the
amazing spider-man 2 some hope has been
restored to me I am Lee
excited to see this movie now so guys as
I said my reviews for Captain America
the Winter Soldier trailer and the age
of extinction transformers for trailer
are currently on my channel those are
the only trailers I'm going to be
talking about today guys thanks so much
for watching and as always if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes